غزه تحديدا عند المستشفى المعمداني كيف
تبدو صوره المعارك على
المحاور المختلفه في مدينه غزه مع عمليات
القصف نعم في البدايه نتحدث عن معارك
الضاريه في شمال في شمال قطاع غزه
بالتحديد في المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه
لمدينه غزه هذه المنطقه التي دخلتها قوات
الاحتلال لثلاث مرات وهذه المره الثالثه
بعد ان اعلنت انهاء عملياتها العسكريه
لعده مرات من منطقه شمال غزه الا ان قوات
الاحتلال تعود مره ومرات اخرى الى نفس
المناطق التي دخلتها من قبل وهذا يدلل على
عدم قدرتها على تقليم قدرات المقاومه او
انهاء قدرات المقاومه في المناطق المختلفه
بالاضافه على عدم قدرتها على الاجهاز على
المقاتلين المتواجدين في مختلف المناطق
حيث اعلنت كتائب القسام يوم امس على
قدرتها على ضرب عدد من اليات قوات
الاحتلال وتفجير عدد من الاليات بالاضافه
الى اجهاز على عدد من الجنود من نقطه فر
بالاضافه الى ذلك قنص ضابطا وجنديا في
الايام الماضيه وهذا يدلل على حجم المعارك
الضاريه والمستمره في جنوب غرب مدينه غزه
بالاضافه لقدره المقاومه المستمره على
مواجهه الاحتلال في كافه المحاور اي محور
يتم دخوله من قبل احتلال هناك مقاومه شرسه
ومختلفه من المقاومه الفلسطينيه ومن كافه
الفصائل لكن ابرز هذه الفصائل هو كتائب
القسام من يواجه دائما ومن يعلن عن ضرب
قوات الاحتلال في حين ان رايا القدس اعلنت
ايضا عن ضربها تحش جنود الاحتلال بالقذائف
والصواريخ قصيره المدى على محاور الغربيه
الجنوبيه لمدينه غزه لكن منذ صباح هذا
اليوم نتحدث عن 17 شهيدا وصلوا الى مستشفى
المعمداني اربعه من هؤلاء الشهداء هم
شهداء اليوم وباقي الشهداء هم انتشال
جثامين مستمر من من مختلف المحاور الذين
ارتقوا خلال الايام السابقه المحاور التي
لا تستطيع الاهالي الوصول اليها وصل بعض
الاهالي اليوم على مختل على بعض المحاور
التي تراجع من من محيطها قو من محيط
تراجعت قوات الاحتلال لكن لا نتحدث عن
انسحاب في هذه اللحظه نتحدث عن تمركز
واعاده تحشد مختلف على كافه المحاور وعلى
كافه المفترقات ولا وهناك يعني دعوات لعدم
توجه المواطنين للمناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه
بسبب انتشار القناصه الاسرائيليه الكثيف
على مختلف المحاور سواء محور الطيران او
على مفترق الطيران مفترق الاتصالات ايضا
مفترق الجامعات ومفترق الصناعه كل هذه
المفترقات تنتشر القناصه الاسرائيليه بشكل
كثيف جدا ما بين 2000 والاخرى تطلق رصاصها
على عدد كبير من المواطنين مما يؤدي الى
استشهاد الفلسطينيين المتوجهين الى تلك
المناطق سواء للاطمئنان على منازلهم او ل
لا قياد ما تبقى من ركام منازلهم